foreign
[Music]
and thanks for attending my talk
um I will be talking about I tend to
promote this and how to study them with
long reads sequencing data
this is a bit of an introduction
my group at the University of Singapore
looks into transcriptomics data and to
illustrate why we think that it's really
interesting I want to show this figure
here this shows the human organism and
there's a lot of different tissues and
the reason why we're interested in RNA
is because RNA is really what differs
between all those different cell types
and what enables this diversity of cell
types in the human body
and so all of these cells have the same
DNA first really is the ionase in the
cell and therefore we have all these
different possible cells that all have
different properties it's not just about
understanding the cells it's also about
understanding changes that happen when
there is a disease such as cancer as the
RNA are often among among the first that
change
technology some transcriptomics so look
to look into that in more detail here I
show
um
a small image of the human chromosome 5
and I selected one region in particular
and then reason you can see there's two
genes
the first Gene here on the left is
transcribed in the direction shown by
the arrow and then there's another Gene
transcribed in the other direction and
often we talk about gene expression and
gene expression describes the process of
generating a gene product from one Gene
and also implicates that there's really
just one product from one Gene and that
is most often not the case
so to show how that looks for this image
here within both of these genes use a
lot of different isoforms and So based
on the number of these isoforms
you can already appreciate that there's
really not just one gene product but
there is a lot of different possible
ways that this Gene can be transcribed
and what happens also is that even for
the same gene Gene product can have
possibly a using different function
it happens after transcription is that
these rnas are spliced
in the same gene some of those can be
non-coding or even then protein coding
and depending on the usage of these
exons you also see that the protein
structure differs and therefore the
function of these rnas
understanding these different ice forms
and cell is really important
and what I've talked about today
clear about the promoter the choice of
the start side what you can see here is
already that there's a lot of different
ways that these genes can be transcribed
and where transcription can be initiated
and that directly impacts this
the RNA isoforms that are generated
to illustrate that a bit more
I'd like to show this example here of a
gene that's well known in cancer that's
erbv2 year BB2 has a number of promoters
I'm just showing two here but you can
already see that depending on the
would be different
and so that might have a consequence and
therefore it might be really important
to understand which promoter is active
and that's what we were interested in
this project to really try to find out
how often our attorney promoters used
and what's the impact of using
alternative promoters
this project was mostly done by a PhD
student in my group Dennis that's a
collaboration with Patrick tan also from
The genome Institute of Singapore
now here we wanted to look into
alternative promoters in cancer
and so if you want to study I kind of
promote this
first thing we would think about is what
kind of Technology
in general
and there are technologies that are
specifically designed for that purpose
such as chip sequencing or cage tag
sequencing now those are really helpful
they can be very accurate and they would
exactly tell us where are these active
promoters that we're interested in the
limitation here is of course that these
are experimental approaches which means
we either have to generate data or we
have to use the data that's publicly
available
but for these two data sources that's
not necessarily on a very large scale
and so as a computation team we work a
lot with publicly available data and for
this project we were actually involved
in a international collaboration and a
domestic Consortium that was called the
pen cancer of whole genomes
and the pancetta NASA full genius
control
that Consortium was really about the
whole genome sequencing of Kansas across
27 cancer types they looked into within
2 600 samples
and iron Asic data available for 1200 of
these samples this was a massive effort
involving more than 700 scientists and
there was all the clinical data
available so there's really a huge
amount of data and these are the kind of
data sets that we would like to study
promoters in but unfortunately there is
no Gypsy or case Tech data so we can't
just use those existing Technologies and
so what we wanted to do was using this
data to identify which promoters are
active
and so I've introduced actually how we
study the transcriptome and the
different isoforms for each gene and
this of course is directly related to
the choice of promoter the idea that we
then had was maybe to use the RNA seek
data to Identity which promoter is
active
so I want to show one example of why
that is principle possible but also why
that is challenging this here shows two
genes that are transcribed in antisense
Direction you can see they're heavily
overlapping and it's of course difficult
to identify which of these isoforms
active from short read sequencing data
this shows such a sequencing track The
Talented some of these reads are
assigned not uniquely to one isoform
and exactly identifying which isoform
we've also be able to identify which
promoter is active as we can exactly
identify the isoform with a promoter but
because of these challenges that might
not feel bust so if we apply isoform
estimate estimation to this example we
get something like that where it
represents one of these isoforms for
these two genes you can see that there's
really a lot of these ice forms are
estimated to be active and that's
partially related due to the uncertainty
in assigning these reads there okay so
there's a lot of uncertainty and that
makes this problem challenging
now it turns out for promoters actually
there's a few things that we can do so
that we're able to deal with this
so I want to introduce the method at
Dennis from a team has developed
up proactive Dev was designed to
estimate promote active D from
our name
so here I show one gene that has four
different isoforms I want to use that to
illustrate how that method works
this Gene can also be Illustrated with
what we call a splicing graph this graph
we can construct by
creating edges and and nodes the nodes
will be the start and end of the exons
so you can illustrate that here also in
that ice form View and the edges will
then be the exons or the interns
and in addition to that we add this root
node and also the leave at the end so
that we get this complete graph here and
this graph represents this team
now there are four different isoforms
and each isoform is one possible path
through that graph and if you want to
estimate is4 expression I have to
estimate the expression associated with
each of these graphs that can be
challenging and that especially due to
things like for example the S between 9
and 10 which is shared with all those
isoforms
now for promoters there's a few things
that really help and the first thing is
if you look into that scene here on the
left
there's four different star types but
actually the first three are very close
by and effect from RNA sequencing data
the resolution is not very high at the
five Prime end so and therefore we might
not even be able to distinguish those
three transcription start sites and
therefore the first simplification that
we make here is that start types that
are very close nearby
we group them together
and for the second simplification that
we then do is that we only use those
risks that are maximally informative to
distinguish between these different
alternative promoters and turns out
those are exactly those reads that um
map to the splice Junctions that are
unique to each of these promoters
and instead of having to estimate is
form expression for all of these
individual isoforms now this problem is
really reduced so essentially look into
just a small part of that graph that
makes this a bit more easily solvable
so this is proactive this method is
implemented and available through
bioconductor
and with the help of a fantastic student
and my team there's also a very nice
workflow available
and you can say that it should be nicely
documented if you have questions you can
also always reach out to us
so this works on any set of RNA
sequencing data it's fast and it's also
easy to use
and so what we can do is we cannot
really apply that to any data set that
we want the first thing we did is we
were looking into some of the public
data sets from encode now encode has
data that involves both chip sequencing
and RNA sequencing so that's the perfect
data set to really test how accurate
proactive works and so here we use h3k
for a Time installation which is
typically seen at promoters
and we calculate the correlation of
promoter activity estimated from these
chipseek data sets and from those inac
data sets that we estimated with
proactive and in this heat map what you
can show in red this is when the
correlation of these two matching cell
lines based on RNA and typically is the
highest as you can see a lot of the
points are on the diagonal this is when
the RNA sequencing is most similar to
the estimates from Chip sequencing data
this video illustrates that we can use
rnac data to obtain a promoter activity
estimates that are comparable with
chipseek but of course we don't need to
do any experiments once we have rnac
data we can just get these estimates we
need directly computationally
and because of that we can apply this to
not just the peacock data set but we can
essentially apply this to a large amount
of data that's publicly available and so
we here we apply this to more than 18
000 samples that include samples from
the pancant analysis of full genomes
Consortium but that also includes
samples from tdga the cancer genome
Atlas also from GTX the genotype tissue
expression project
so in total there's this large number of
samples covering 42 cancer types and a
lot of different tissues and a lot of
these samples also have clinical data
available so that scale is possible
because of the availability of RNA
sequencing data
so if we apply that and we estimate
promote activity for all these samples
the first thing we see if we generate
this kind of T sneak plot is that the AC
cluster by tissue and that's largely
expected and that is also what we would
see if we would do the same analysis
with gene expression so that's not so
surprising because essentially promote
activity just captures gene expression
but there's also something in addition
to gene expression that we get and this
can be Illustrated in the following plot
here on the x-axis that is the average
gene expression and on the y-axis that
is the average Major promoter activity
so a point that on the diagonal these
are genes that just use one promoter so
the promoter completely explains the
gene expression but all of these points
that are below the diagonal those are
genes with a major promoter does not
completely explain the gene expression
and so these are genes that use
alternative promoters and that's
something that we can now really study
in detail
to illustrate how that looks I'd like to
show this example of a gene that is
called DJ B1 and that has two possible
promoters and what you can see here in
the in the top line that's the
expression from the central nervous
system and you can see that these
tissues use the second promoter whereas
all the remaining tissues essentially
use the first promoter there's very
clear distinction in which promoter is
used
but if you look at the overall
expression level actually the expression
is essentially very similar so we would
just look at gene expression you would
not see that there's any difference but
if we look into the promotes activity we
can see that there's a very clear change
and then of course might potentially
have functional consequences
now this is one example but we observe
of course many more we do see that these
alternative promoters are used
specifically in all of these tissues
that we studied so there's a lot of
alternative promoters that we can detect
then otherwise do not show any change in
overall Gene Express
now we can also ask what's the relation
between promoters and isoforms
and one thing that we see is that a lot
of these promoters actually are directly
connected to a single isoform which
means the choice of the promoter already
defines the isoform expression so
there's a very close relationship
between transcription regulation to the
choice of promoter and the RNA is that
is generated so not all of this
diversity that we observe at the iPhone
level is due to the splicing process
once the promoters decided
spicing is then post less than a
post-transcriptional process and so it's
really closely connected and frequency
determined pre-transcriptionally
if you look into these major isoform
switches we also see that again that
really a large fraction of ISO on
Switching appears to be closely
associated with a choice of promoter and
so splicing of course is important but
it really shows that spicing is just one
aspect of generating this huge diversity
of isoforms that we see in the cell
and so one more aspect that we also
looked into is what is actually the
consequence of changing the promoter so
if we compare the meta isoform to the
alternative isoform we do see that it of
course affects the sequence of the five
primary Theory that's expected but you
also see that it can change the coding
sequence and the three prime UTI so the
choice of promoter really might have an
impact on even the structure of the
protein and other things so there seems
to be some kind of Regulation that goes
beyond just the selection of the start
side
so the next thing we want to look into
was finding out which of these
parameters are associated with which
cancer types and so we've compared
cancer with normal samples here and so
we did that by first matching the
expression of tissues it's not obvious
all the time which cancer type to match
to which healthy tissue and so we first
did that based on this clustering things
that we couldn't match in any good way
we removed from this analysis to avoid
any large mismatch between tissues
that based on this Association we can
now compare cancer and normal tissues
and there's a few interesting things
that we can see and so this heat map
here I like to show because of course
all of us have seen a lot of heat Maps
we work with gene expression data that's
one of the first things that we would
always look into but this heat map is
different in a sense that all of these
genes that we show here do not overall
show a change in gene expression it's
really a specific promoter that has
changed let's hear for kidney cancer
samples between Cancer and normal
at the bottom you can see the first
graph that is the change in the
alternative promoter and below that that
is the change in gene expression so you
can really see changes at the level of
the promoter that's not reflected in
lean expression levels and some things
that we might otherwise would have
missed
you can also look into more details
within a specific answer type for
example in breast cancer we can see that
there's different subtypes they're
specifically associated with the choice
of promoters for some genes so by
ranking genes by the the specific
promoter we can discriminate these
subtests even within a single cancer
type
we can also look into the opposite that
is we look into promoters that are
associated with Cancers across all of
these different cancer types we do see
examples like this Gene here which has
business promoted too that's generally
expressed in healthy tissue but that
seems to be reducing an expression in a
lot of the cancer types and again that's
something that's very specific to this
promoter here it's not a change in
overall gene expression
okay so one of the reasons we looked
into these large-scale datasets also
that there's more data available it's
not just the expression data so the
promoters that we see we can also
associate that with the other data
that's available and one of the
interesting things to look out of course
is
clinical data so here we looked into
patient survival
and so what we did is we identified for
each of these promoters for the gene the
top um 10 outlier patients that had the
highest promoter activity and compared
it to the lower 90 percent
and then we calculated the significance
uh whether there's a significant
difference
in these two groups based on the
expression threshold
we did that all the promoters identified
the one that showed the highest
significant Association and compared it
to the remaining promoters and that
allowed us to find out whether there is
an association at the level of the
promoter or whether that Association is
generally uh
um whether we observe that as a general
trend for the complete team
what we get from this is the following
finger here in the x-axis that is the
adjusted P value for the association of
with Survivor for the alternative
promoter and on the y-axis this is the
significance of the association for all
the other promoters so there's a few
points here on the diagonal those genes
are really genes where the gene
expression is associated with patient
Survivor we can also see these points
you highlighted in Orange they're very
close to the x-axis and those are genes
with this a very specific Association
observable only for this alternative
promoter with all the other promoters do
not seem to have a significant
Association
and so that brings me also back to the
first example that I wanted to show that
the airbnb2
these two promoters here
and those are great quickly show my
patients and what we see is that for the
first promoter there's essentially no
significant Association whether this
mode is highly active or lowly active we
do not see this association with
survival however for the second promoter
we do see this Association and it's
clearly significant Association which
tells us that this promoter specifically
can discriminate patients that show poor
survival proper nodes from those that
show a better prognosis and better
Survivor
now as you can see there's really a
specific to the promoter here
so there's one thing that we know about
lower grade glioma and that is that
there are also certain mutations that
frequently occur
and so we can also look into that as
these also might explain the same
association with clinical
Survivor that we see and so that also
illustrates again why it's so nice to be
able to work with these rich data
sources that not just have one data type
but multiple data tabs so here we are
using the mutation data from The genome
sequencing data
there's a few genes that are frequently
mutated and they're partially also
mutually exclusive so you can see these
two groups the one with idh1 and p53 and
the other one was egfr and the P10
mutation and so then we group that based
on their co-occurrence with the erbb2 P2
promoter activation
and so we do see that there is Killian
Association and that could tell us also
that this association with survival that
we see could also be a downstream effect
based on changes in in these genes these
mutations might introduce regulatory
changes and so the observation that we
have for BB2 might just be Downstream of
that
and in fact if we look into them in case
we do see that there is an association
with survival for idea H1 for example
whether the percentage is present or not
really tells us about the patient
Survivor
okay so the question is how does that
look if we now remove those patients
that actually have a mutations from
patients that do not have a mutation in
these four genes can we still use the
erbb2 promoted to discriminate Survivor
and yes we can see that it still is
predictive indicating that this
expression data is
specific data for this ew2 P2 promoter
can be informative even in the absence
of mutations
this really suggests that there's
something more It's Not Just Dance
augmentation the arena Association here
that seems to be high informative
okay so that's the first part to
summarize that really I've shown that we
can estimate promoter activity from Ina
sequencing data
we see that I come from with a display
to the specific regulation and that they
impact isoform diversity
and we study scans Associated promoters
and often we see that these are
independent from Gene Expressions so we
would easily miss that if you only look
into gene expression then one thing that
I really think nice illustrates this
Association
of promote activities when we study
survival you can see that some of those
might be predictive and that this
Association of survival is specific to
the promoter and again not available at
the gene expression level
okay so this paper was published so you
can read about it you can also try this
tool one limitation here is that this is
specific to annotations so we rely on
the annotations of promoters to be able
to estimate them so that brings into the
next topic they've mentioned already I
want to talk a bit more about long read
RNA sequencing which I think really will
make a huge difference to
um transcriptomics
and one of the advantages of courses
that we can go beyond the expression now
we can start to look into individual
isoforms here you can see the same
example with a short read sequencing
data
of course it's difficult to associate
these reads with these transcripts
reasons are among others that there's a
lot of specific biases that we can also
measure and that we can partially deal
with but these really make it difficult
to identify which isoform is active
and so we can do more replicates but it
might just be the same as replicates do
not necessarily solve that problem
so if we look into long read data what
we can see is that there's really this
Association here
between reads and isoforms that greatly
help to identify which of these ice
forms is active
and so not only helps with that it also
allows us to identify new isoforms
things that are not present in the
annotations
and so for the next
um a few minutes I want to specifically
talk about this project which is
actually where I'm a collaborator so
it's mostly done by Patrick Dunn and
Wang and Patrick Tan's lab and that was
also recently published and here we
looked into long-range transcriptome
sequencing data for gastric cancer
we've been using the peg bio ISO seek
system
so that system involves of course a data
generation but it also involves this
pipeline which generates high quality
isoforms and the system as the advantage
that it's accurate and for the isoforms
that we get are of very high confidence
so compared to shortly data really the
advantages that we can get essentially
full length reads assigned to these
isoforms
and we can also use that to identify new
isoforms that are present in the RNA
that are not present in the annotations
so for this project what we did was we
sequence 10 gastric cancer cell lens and
they were chosen to really reflect a bit
of diversity in terms of gastric cancer
they included chromosome unstable cell
lines microsatellite unstable cell lines
they also included two EV positive cell
lines and a genome stable gas again as
saline each of those was then sequenced
with four flow cells generating about 26
gigabyte of raw sequencing data and in
total we get about 27 000 non-redundant
full-length ice forms per cell line
so here and B what you can see is the
different kinds of iPhone that we can
get and back that shows the reference
and in red these are the ice forms that
perfectly match in terms of spice
Junctions to the references
and then in green we have these passion
matches that's something that can
um possibly be a false positive those
might be very interesting but they are
also a bit more difficult to study and
so we particularly look into these um
here shown in blue and in purple those
are the new isoforms that either use
existing Junctions or that even use new
Junctions the one thing that we see is
that we look into all these isoforms
many of the ice forms that we get from
these data sets are essentially not
annotated these are novel isoforms and
so if we compare this across all the
cell lines the more data we add
the more isoforms do we identify now
those that are annotated they seem to
saturate at some point whereas those are
not annotated still increase and that's
partially expected of course because
annotations really are a very specific
set that reflects a certain
um
data set that was used for these
annotations and there's of course a lot
of limitations on what can go into
annotations and so the more we sequence
the more new ISO phones we will get but
this does not necessarily mean that
these are all highly expressed or that
all of these are functionally important
but it really illustrates that there's a
huge diversity and not all of that is
reflected in annotations
again going back to this example of
erbb2 you can also see here what we get
in terms of new isoforms on top here in
red that's shown what's annotated
and then in blue and purple we can
really see the number of isoforms that
we can observe that are not annotated
and so there's a huge diversity here in
addition to what's annotated
the different types of splicing events
of course I've talked a lot about
alternative first exons but there's also
I turned a 5.3 Prime Supply size
alternative last exons and run retention
axon skipping removing exclusive axons
and
with this data look into all of those
but one thing that we see is that the
alternative first axons so the
alternative promoters seem to be the
most frequent event that we can observe
and for one thing that we also see here
and that's similar to what we was doing
before is that the choice of promoter
impacts not just the five parameter but
also the coding sequence and the three
prime VTR really indicating that there
is this close relationship between
transcriptional regulation and the
choice of isoform and Gene product that
will then be generated
so one aspect that's interesting here is
again that we can use these annotations
and then look into Data that's available
publicly available because there's so
much short reader and AC data you can
now use proactive to estimate promote
activity using these new annotations but
on existing data we can also estimate
activity on the long read data that also
works well but of course the advantage
with publicly available data is that we
have such an amount of Rich data
resources and so that's what we then
looked into next
and so here what you can see on top
that's the data that we get we analyzed
mode activity in tcga samples and and
samples from a Singapore specifically
look into gastric cancer and using
proactive again this made promote
activity
but different to what I presented before
now we can use these annotations from
the Longview sequencing data and that
really allows us to identify promoters
that are not in the annotations they're
not present there and so promoters that
might have been missed in the previous
analysis
and so one thing that we see then is
that um really there's quite a few of
those
and I want to specifically highlight the
association with survive survival again
because it really nice illustrates this
relationship here what we looked into is
the association of survival for the
novel promoter and for the non-promotive
and we observe of course all these kinds
of possible scenarios there are genes
where the genix version again is
associated with Survivor and there are
some with just the annotated are
associated with Survivor but we also
have observe cases where this via novel
promoter that has not been described
previously it seems to have an
association that was not otherwise
otherwise observable
for turret that and more detail this
shows three examples here on top that is
the non-promoter for these genes and on
on the bottom that is the novel promoter
and sometimes the association is
stronger sometimes differences are not
as strong but for some cases we also see
an opposite effect indicating really
that the choice of promoter might be
important and that not all of the
promoters
that are important are comprehensively
annotated
so to summarize this part I've
Illustrated this project where we
generated the full length transcriptome
data set for gastric anthocellites
across different subtypes so thereby
itself is really a huge resource to
understand variation in different
gastric cancer and different gastric
cancers
we saw that the language data can be
used to start a study novel transient
ISO first and also alternative promoters
and by combining these data sets with
short data that's publicly available
again study the association again with
survival we do see that this seems to be
a usage of a term for models that can
potentially be biologically important
okay so just the last slide I've not
talked about this today much but we also
developed methods for long read rnasic
data analysis and so I wanted to post
the GitHub link here you can try all
these methods and
let us know what you think we're always
happy about feedback
okay with that I'd like to thank
everyone involved here in particular for
the first project that's a form PhD
student Dennis demichiolo who developed
proactive and also Joseph Lee was a
visiting student really greatly
contributed to the implementation of
proactive who made it available to buy
connector and who also developed this
workflow so if you try that out it
should be nicely documented
I also want a particularly think of
course Patrick tan who was a close
collaborator for both of these projects
for the peacock project and of course
was the main person behind the gastric
cancer project together with one from
his lab
right with that I'd like to thank all of
you for listening to this talk and feel
free to reach out if you have any
questions